estamos de regreso para repasar las
principales noticias de la economía
internacional y ya nos acompaña para
ello en el estudio Daniela Blandón
Buenos días Hola Buenos días Rosa
Daniela empezamos con una buena noticia
podríamos decir y es que el Banco
Mundial digamos mejora sus perspectivas
económicas para la región de América
Latina y el Caribe Sí Rosa y es una
noticia buena pero agridulce al mismo
tiempo le voy a decir por qué el
organismo multilateral cree que la
región podría crecer 1,4% en 2023 y 2,4%
en 2024 la cifra para este año es una
décima superior a la que tenían en enero
Sí pero el Banco Mundial reconoce que
sigue estando por debajo de lo esperado
debido principalmente al descenso de los
precios de las materias primas y también
a los altos intereses Aunque varios
países de la región ya han venido
estabilizando sus tipos de interés como
por ejemplo Brasil que los mantuvo
recientemente y chile que acaba de dejar
los intactos en 11,25%
pero Daniela después la inflación
persistente es uno de los problemas
principales de la región no Así es en
estas cifras con corte a diciembre que
vamos a ver se evidencia como hay países
como Argentina en los que los precios de
hoy Son el doble de los que eran hace un
año y como otros alcanzan cifras de
inflación no vistas en décadas como
Colombia o chile que están por encima
del 13% alrededor del 13% es por eso que
los líderes de México Argentina Brasil
Bolivia Chile Colombia Cuba y Honduras
entre otros países de la región
celebrarán este miércoles una Cumbre con
la lucha antiinflación como objetivo
principal eso fue convocado hace un mes
por el mandatario mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador el intercambio en
importación y exportación de alimentos y
la eliminación de aranceles son algunas
de las propuestas que ha planteado el
mandatario mexicano veremos Cómo va esta
reunión Daniela Pero por otro lado la
empresa la compañía Johnson propone
pagar indemnizaciones por sus talcos
para bebé por qué pues un tema que lleva
varios años en el ojo de las autoridades
y es que esta empresa ofreció repartir
alrededor de 8.900 millones de dólares
entre más de 60.000 consumidores
afectados para resolver sus demandas
esto por la supuesta presencia de
componentes cancerígenos en sus polvos
de talcos para bebé en América del Norte
y es que este producto es señalado de
contener asbestos un mineral con efectos
nocivos para la salud y la multinacional
lleva años enfrentando Problemas legales
por supuestamente haber contribuido al
desarrollo de cáncer de ovario en las
consumidoras en las mamás de acuerdo el
acuerdo final que da en manos de un juez
de quiebras ya que esa multinacional le
endilgó a uno de sus filiales las
posibles responsabilidades por estos
casos y la declaró en quiebra pero es
muy difícil que prospere porque la firma
no tiene dificultades financieras ya el
gigante farmacéutico anunció el año
pasado que en 2023 iba a suspender la
venta de sus talcos para bebés en todo
el mundo dos años después de hacerlo en
Estados Unidos y también en Canadá y
Daniela vamos ahora con una entidad
financiera que ha estado en el foco de
la atención mediática no y es que hoy ha
de celebrar reunión de accionistas Sí
Rosa Un día después de una tensa
asamblea del legendario Credit suiz que
está en proceso de compra por parte de
este que es el mayor banco suizo en un
proceso bastante polémico pues hoy el
turno Entonces como lo dices para los
socios del comprador de uvs que ya salió
a aclarar que todavía no ha tomado
decisiones por ejemplo con respecto a
puestos de trabajo Esta es una de las
mayores preocupaciones Dentro de este
acuerdo también resaltó que no le espera
una tarea fácil como vamos a escuchar
el 19 de marzo fue un shock para todos
nosotros para Us para Suiza sé que aquí
en Ibis enfrentamos bien los cambios sin
embargo también sabemos que la
adquisición de Credit suiz será un gran
desafío pero estoy convencido de que
esta adquisición traerá consigo grandes
oportunidades se espera que se cree un
negocio con más de 5 billones de dólares
en activos de inversión
y Daniela los granos ucranianos tienen
envilo a otros agricultores europeos
Pues el ministro de agricultura de
Polonia
renunció a su cargo hoy en medio de la
creciente ira entre los agricultores de
ese país por el impacto que han tenido
en los precios las importaciones de
granos desde Ucrania la razón
básicamente Es que la comisión europea
decidió extender las importaciones
libres de impuestos para el grano de
Ucrania hasta junio de 2024 para
contribuir con el tema de la guerra eso
significa que grandes cantidades de
grano en ucranianos que son más baratos
que los producidos en la Unión europea
pues terminan en otros estados de Europa
central y esto afecta a los precios y
las ventas de los agricultores locales
además de Polonia varios países ya le
han pedido la comisión europea que actúe
al respecto pues para proteger los
intereses de sus propios productores
Daniela Muchísimas gracias por este
repaso económico nos vemos mañana y a
ustedes Muchísimas gracias por su
atención sigan con nosotros